[Music]
you hungry little
guy
[Music]
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever with
a please no it's so hot it's really
hurting ow ow ow you deserve to be seen
with somebody is f ah say when never
John bury me and cheese oh I apologize
in advance the eating you're about to
see will not be pretty and if you have
young children this would be a good time
for them to leave the
room hey Junior this is fck my father
you ever jumped a train I've never
jumped here's I stop really
where
[Applause]
oh OD you think he'd see that coming
let's get it I deserve to
be wait for
it it's
[Music]
h
color me
[Music]
intrigued